If you want to start making $500 or more
a day trading, there are two negative
trading loops that you have to be aware
of and break out of. If you don't, you
will be stuck struggling at trading for
years. I see it constantly, myself
included, was stuck in these two loops.
And they are the whole reason you are
probably right now jumping from strategy
to strategy trying to be consistently
profitable. And so I want to walk you
through what these two loops are and how
you can break out of them to eventually
becoming consistently profitable. The
whole journey of becoming a consistent
trader is a struggle in the beginning
where you are generally just
consistently losing or just not making
any money. And once you actually break
out of these loops, your equity curve
and profitability will go from
flatlining to losing to consistently
profitable. This is the whole goal that
all of us as traders want. And so let me
walk you through what these are and how
you can break out of them. And so I look
at trading as there are three stages of
becoming profitable. And the first stage
is that you are stuck in what is called
a learning loop. And so how this works
is you come into trading, you know, you
first start, you find a strategy you
like and you start testing it out. And
so you do this for a couple weeks,
couple months, you know, you have some
success, but eventually you start to
become not consistently profitable with
it. And so you stop getting good results
or you're just not getting the results
you want. And so then of course like
logically with anything else in life you
look to go back and learn more because
generally with anything in life is if
you learn more you become better at it.
So you either look to find a new
strategy or you look to add either
different candlestick patterns or other
indicators to the strategy. And so then
again you start to test that out. But lo
and behold you aren't getting the
results you want. And so you go back to
the drawing board of either scrapping
everything trying to find a new strategy
or adding new things to it. And so you
get stuck in this cycle. I was stuck in
this cycle for years jumping from
strategy to strategy because I didn't
find something that worked for me. But I
also didn't stop myself from being stuck
in this cycle. And so we're going to
talk about how you can break out of
this. But first, I want to talk about
the second loop that you can get stuck
in. Because once you break out of this,
you're going to go right into another
trap that I call the self- sabotage
loop. Once you learn more about trading,
you'll start to realize that there are a
lot of emotions in it, especially when
you start trading real money. Things can
get very intense. You can get emotional.
You can start FOMOing into trades,
getting nervous, frustrated. Impulsivity
comes in your trading. And so there's
this whole web of emotions that
negatively impact your trading. And so
all of these different feelings, greed,
euphoria, desperation, they make it so
you are self-sabotaging
your trading. And so, let me illustrate
what this can look like and what my
self-sabotage loop looked like because
you will start to see how this cycle
works and how it self-sabotaged me and
will give you insight to what yours
might look like. And so, for me, my
biggest issue with trading was I had the
fear of being wrong. I was scared of a
trade losing, losing money during that
trade. And so any time that I would see
a potential opportunity come, whatever
strategy I was trading, I would start to
get nervous when the time came to enter.
And so I that fear would come in and
take control of me. And so then I would
skip the trade. And of course, generally
because I'm following a strategy that
works most of the time, that would work
out. That trade would have worked out
and I would have been able to make a
profitable trade. And so instead,
because I skipped out on that trade, I
became frustrated because I missed out
on the money I could have made from that
trade, which was frustrating. And so
that frustration would stay with me as
I'm still watching the charts. And what
it would do is I would be sitting there
waiting for another trade opportunity to
come and something would kind of start
to set up. But let's say if I have a
checklist, you know, of five things I'm
looking for to jump into a trade, three
out of five of them would show up. and I
would say, you know what, this is good
enough. I'm gonna jump in because I
don't want to miss out on this trade
because I did that just for the last one
and it worked out. And so I FOMOed into
a trade now because I was frustrated and
it allowed my emotions to take control
of me. And so from there, generally
because I'm jumping in on a bad trade
now based on FOMO is it would turn into
a loss and I would become even more
frustrated. And sometimes this would
turn into something even worse, tunnel
vision, panic. You know, I would start
to revenge trade even and I would take
more losses. But eventually I would get
to a point where I say, "Okay, I have to
take a break. I got to be done with
trading for the day. I need to either
take tomorrow off or, you know, somehow
reset and come back to the drawing
board, right?" And of course, I would
reset. But those emotions and underlying
reasons of why I, you know, had the fear
of being wrong would restart and this
cycle would just continue. And so that
would be how I would be stuck in. I
still broke out of the learning loop,
but now I'm stuck in another loop of
just self-sabotaging myself over and
over. And this is something I constantly
see other people struggling with.
They'll have a strategy, but they'll
have all these emotions that are just
negatively impacting their trading. And
if we don't learn how to deal with these
and stop them from controlling our
actions, we're never going to get to the
end goal of becoming consistently
profitable. And so, I want to walk you
through how we can combat these three
stages. how we can go from being stuck
in the learning loop to being in the
self-sabotage loop and breaking out of
both of those to become consistently
profitable. And I'm confident that I
know what I have will help you because
I've heard it from other people that
they were jumping from strategy to
strategy until they learned some of this
stuff I'm about to teach you and it
helped them break out of those loops and
become consistently profitable. And so
let's first work on how we can break out
of the learning loop because that's
generally the one that I think stops the
most people. And so the first thing with
doing that is you have to find a
strategy that works for you. And so my
strategy is super simple. Over time, I
realized that, you know, through all the
strategies I was trying out, all I could
really be confident in that, hey, I know
how to find clear support or resistance
zones. And I can see that the market can
clearly bounce off those levels. And so
I created a strategy based on that. All
this does is it's a simple process of I
wait for the market to come down to the
one of these levels and then I look for
on a smaller time frame chart. Generally
I trade on a one minute chart and then I
essentially follow my step pattern and
then step two is waiting for you know
kind of the current trend to come down
and then step three is I look for kind
of a reversal pattern and then I jump in
betting that the market is going to go
higher and I usually go for you know a
three times riskreward ratio. So if I'm
risking something like $150 here I'll
eventually manage the trade and you know
here I made about $600 on a trade so it
was about a 4x trade. And so that was a
really nice profit. And so this isn't
something I'm going to go into a ton of
detail here because I have a ton of
YouTube videos explaining this, but the
whole idea is that you need to narrow
down your focus. And so for me, that's
what looking solely at reversal patterns
did is instead of trying to, you know,
catch every swing in the market of,
okay, I'm going to catch a reversal
here. I'm gonna look for a continuation
trade up here. Instead, I'm just looking
for one specific thing every day. And
that's all I do. What I've realized as
well is because all I do is I really
just look at the candlestick patterns. I
use just a couple of trend lines, you
know, support and resistance zones that
it simplifies things really well and it
allows you to actually trade this on
really any market or time frame because
these candlestick patterns are just a
reflection of the price and what the
market is doing. And so this can apply
to any market. And one thing that
narrowed this down even more for me, and
I've always found that to get out of
that learning loop, the better thing to
do is take things away. What can you do
that will take away things that are
negatively impacting your trading? If
trading, you know, three different
patterns is negatively impacting your
trading, take out one or two that you
don't feel like you're consistently as
profitable with. And so another thing
that really helped me narrow things down
over time was looking at kind of 30
minute reversals is what I realized is
just consistently looking at the market
is looking at the NASDAQ futures and the
S&P 500 futures is 30 minutes after the
open. If on these charts the market
opens at 6:30 which is West Coast time,
it's 30 minutes around 7:00 is that's
when the markets reverse a lot. And so
that's how I narrowed down my focus even
more and stuck with a really solid
strategy. So I, you know, didn't don't
go back in that learning loop. You got
to be aware these loops once you break
out of it, you can go right back into it
if you're not careful. And so that's
something I'm always working towards is
just getting better and and more narrow
focus is every chart of these. These are
from one specific month. And you can see
at 7:00 there's a really nice the market
opens, kind of moves down, makes a
really nice double bottom, and then
reverses. And so this is something that
I find that is super repeatable and that
this is how you want to approach trading
is find something that you are confident
in and that you can consistently do day
in and day out. Because if you spend
your time trying to just jump around
and, you know, react to the what the
market is doing instead of going in and
having a plan, you're not going to
become consistently profitable. And so
that's something that I have found to be
really beneficial. And another really
cool tool that I actually made, I call
the news navigator, is when you're
trading futures and the S&P 500 is that
well, there's a lot of news that comes
out. And so just to quickly show you is
here is a news release platform I use.
It's just called Forex Factory and it
just shows every day, okay, there is
news releases that are either red and
you got to be really aware of or there's
just yellow ones that aren't a big deal
or some orange ones. And what I realized
is this doesn't actually do a good job
of saying what is important or not. And
so what I did is I just looked at, you
know, every release and took data over
time of saying, okay, what's the
release? What's the potential movement?
And so is there actually potential
movement? And so can I trade through the
release? And so there's not many that
happen 15 minutes after the market
opens, but there's a ton that happen an
hour before the market opens and 30
minutes after the market opens. And so
this 30 minute one that happens after
the market open, these ones are really
important to pay attention to because
there's some that you got to be aware of
that cause massive movement and some
that are just no movement at all and you
can trade through. And so that is
something that I found really really
helpful with just narrowing my focus
down even more. And so that's really how
you have to break out of that learning
loop is find something that you like and
stick to it. It doesn't have to be my
strategy. We all have different trading
personalities and what you know makes
sense for us and what we feel
comfortable with. I feel comfortable
with taking reversal trades because
that's what I just mentally makes sense.
I can see that okay when the market
comes down for me I see that okay
there's a good riskreward here and that
makes a lot of sense for me versus some
people they're just better at
continuation trades but for me mentally
that just doesn't work. And so the
second thing is once you break out of
that, you're going to be put right into
the self-sabotage loop. And so there's
four steps to breaking out of this loop.
And so the important ones are is
building awareness of what your emotions
are that negatively impact your trading.
You know, my big ones were, you know,
the fear of being wrong. And so starting
to become aware of just what those are.
The frustration of missing profits.
Maybe yours is FOMO. Maybe yours is
greed or desperation to, you know, make
a lot of money quickly. And so you have
to then once you become aware of what
those emotions are, you got to
understand how you react impulsively to
those actions. And so for me, you know,
my fear of being wrong would lead me to
skip a trade and that I don't
necessarily want to logically skip a
trade. I want to logically be following
my plan. But as humans, we follow our
emotions a lot. We're emotional beings.
They take control over us and
impulsively cause us to do things. And
so a lot of the time is we are
reactionary based on our emotions. And
what we need to learn to do is we need
to overcome our impulsivity to react to
those emotions. And so instead we want
to react how we want. And so instead,
what a really good way to illustrate
this is I still when a trade comes up, I
still have that innate fear of being
wrong. And so I get nervous and instead
of skipping a trade out of that fear, I
have created a new pattern and a way I
react. Instead of reacting based on my
emotions and my fear, I say no, I want
to jump into this trade. And so when I
would jump into that trade, it would
break that self-sabotage loop and it
would start this new loop of I jump in a
trade and I would start to build
confidence in my ability to trade. And
so then it would come up to the next
trade and I would still have that same
emotion of being fear fear of being
wrong, but instead I've now started to
learn to control those actions and I
consistently react accordingly and how I
want to. And so that's the biggest thing
to help break yourself out of that loop
is instead of letting your emotions
control you. You feel your emotions,
accept that you feel that way. It's okay
to be scared that you're going to be
wrong. We're not robots. It's a part of
who we are. And instead, you just say,
"Okay, I feel that way, but I'm still
going to do what I want to do." And so,
this is the basic framework of breaking
out of that learning loop, breaking out
of the self-sabotage loop, and becoming
consistently profitable. Now, just
because you know this doesn't mean it's
not going to be easy. It's still going
to be really hard. And so, what I've
done to help accelerate this for you is
I've created a 90-day confident trader
program that is designed to help you
break out of both of these loops and
become consistently profitable as fast
as possible. And I'm confident that this
will help you drastically accelerate and
improve your trading because I've seen
it do that for people already. People
that were struggling for so long, they
were losing and just consistently, you
know, in that part of the learning curve
where they're just not making consistent
money. And then they join the program
and they start to see that change in
their equity curve where they're
consistently profitable month after
month. And it's just awesome to see
where these people are saying, you know,
they've been struggling and not
consistent for three and a half years
and they're way more consistent than
ever. You know, they feel like they
finally found their strategy if they're
using my reversal strategy. But it's
also helping them just break those
cycles that you're just stuck in as a
trader. And there have been people that
have had big 50% account returns after a
year. This person down here almost has a
100% return. And so what I want this to
illustrate is that it's helped a lot of
other people break out of these learning
loops. I can never, you know, guarantee
that you are going to make $96,000 in 2
months, but I can guarantee that this is
going to drastically accelerate your
learning curve and your process getting
through these loops. And so, let me
illustrate to you how this program is
laid out and how it's going to help you
break out of the learning loop and then
the self-sabotage loop. And so first is
right away when you jump in is you are
going to get access to my whole trading
strategy and everything I have and know
about what makes a profitable strategy
and how to become consistently with it
and manage and grow an account over time
and keeping you out of being stuck in
that cycle. And so the first thing that
it's going to address is it's just going
to jump start your trading journey. It's
going to help you build your foundation
of how to understand everything that I'm
talking about going forwards. But then
it's going to walk you through how to
consistently look for reversals because
again, that's what my strategy focuses
on. It's going to give you a deep dive
into how I identify those patterns, the
early shifts that the market has and
teach you advanced market movement that
will help you realize when these signals
are going to happen. And so this dives
into way more depth than what my YouTube
videos do. Those really give a good
overview of my entry checklist and how I
trade. But this gives you a super deep
dive into everything about that. And
then as well, it'll start to go into how
to consistently manage trades. It'll go
into my road map of those 30 minute
after the market open reversals. It'll
give you that news release navigator
that we talked about. And it will just
go through. I have hours and months of
trade examples in there. And the biggest
thing about this is probably it helps
you know when to avoid entering trades
even when the signal shows up because
what I see a lot of people doing is they
will follow my five-step checklist but
there's times when you actually
shouldn't be entering in a trade and
there's certain signals that show that.
And then the last really crucial thing
is learning how to grow your account and
treat trading like a business. I have a
three-step sizing growth plan in there
that will really help you know how to
scale properly and go at this the right
way. The biggest thing about trading and
breaking that learning loop is you need
to become process focused and focus on
consistently executing the same strategy
because otherwise you're just going to
be stuck in this learning loop over and
over. And so all this will help you
break out of that learning loop. And
then we go on to the second part of the
program, which is really where the 90
days comes in. I have a 9-week framework
that is going to now start focusing on
that self-sabotage loop. And instead of
you getting stuck in that, it's going to
help you break out of that and work
towards becoming consistently profitable
with your strategy. What this is going
to do is it's going to be giving you
weekly actionable steps and systems that
you can use to start becoming aware of
how things are negatively affecting you.
It's going to help you build your
emotional matrix and figure out what's
actually affecting you, the level that
it's affecting you, and how you can
actually change how these negatively
affect you. And then as well, it's going
to start to bring in some other concept
of your mental capital and your body
battery and how do you you can deal with
loss streaks and change those around.
There are a ton of destructive emotions
that affect your trading and you need to
learn how to control them. And so what
this is going to do is there are
frameworks in there that I call the
stimulus gap response framework that is
going to stop you from becoming
impulsive. and you want to it'll help
you react how you want. I have another
really really cool system in there that
I call the emotional spectrum that is
going to help you stay calm amid all the
chaos and help you know, okay, what
emotions am I okay to trade during and
when I feel certain emotions, what do I
do and how do I stay away from starting
to revenge trade and get out of control.
And then the last whole phase of this is
how you start to work to becoming
consistently profitable. How you start
narrowing things down, stopping the loss
streaks and the boom and bust cycles
that really start to happen when you
start to get close to becoming
profitable. And then as well, what it'll
start do is it'll start to ingrain these
things into muscle memory. So instead of
having that self-sabotage loop be, you
know, a negative pattern, you're going
to break out of that and you're going to
start to make positive patterns and
loops that you are stuck in that are
beneficial to your trading. And so
essentially successful trading will
start to become like muscle memory for
you. That's what's so powerful about
this is you are think of everything like
muscle memory. all our how we react to
things and how this self-sabotage loop
works is it's just muscle memory. Your
body is used to saying, "Okay, I'm
nervous. I'm scared. I'm going to stay
away from and get away from what is
making me nervous and scared and not do
whatever that thing is." And instead, we
reprogram our minds and create different
pathways and muscle memory to create
positive emotional loops that positively
affect our trading. And so all of this
you can find in my self-paced ondemand
90 confident trader program and you can
get that in the link below. And so
really what you get access with this is
everything that I have built out that is
going to help you break out of that
learning loop and then into the
self-sabotage loop and break out of that
and accelerate your trading to becoming
consistently profitable. And so there
are a there's hours and hours on my
strategy and how to consistently execute
that because you know that's one of the
most important things. But then you also
have that nine weeks of your trading
mindset focused work. You're going to
get a lifetime access to all this.
You're going to get a ton of tools,
guides, routines, and as well as
frameworks to help build your trading
career. You're going to get that
newsreleas navigator that I talked about
earlier. And as well, there's a couple
of things I've added in as exclusive
bonuses. I've added in lifetime
community access to my exclusive trading
chat room. And generally, this is a
monthly subscription and so it's going
to save you a ton of money for that. But
as well, this is really helpful in once
you've gone through this whole program
and used all these tools, gone through
those 90 days, you're still going to
want continued help and education. And
what this community does is it's an
extremely active community that helps
each other. And not just from me, but
everyone else there is focus on the same
thing. And they're going to know all
these materials that you're working on,
too. And so it's going to help you
bounce ideas off of each other and as
well off of me and get help anytime you
need. Another thing that I added is I
have learned a ton about the mental side
of trading from my actual trading coach.
He focuses mainly on the mental side of
trading with me. And what we did is we
sat down for an hour and a half session
and talked about what it will take for
someone starting with this strategy. he
knows this strategy very well because
I've worked with him for coming up on
four years now is how we can tailor all
of this and best make it work for you.
Someone coming from a beginner or you
know stuck in those loops and how they
can start to break them going forward.
And so this is an hour and a half
session that is highly focused on that
and I think you will find it insanely
beneficial to have someone else's
perspective as well on all this. And
then the last thing is because I'm so
confident in this program drastically
improving and changing your trading just
from how much effort I've put into it,
but also just reviews from other people
is that I have a 100% guarantee to give
you a refund, no questions asked, in the
first 30 days. If you, for any reason,
it doesn't matter, want a refund, just
email me and I will happily give it to
you. The idea is this is, you know, I
understand there's a lot of shady stuff
out there online. And I just want to
make this kind of a risk-free investment
for you to help accelerate your journey
in trading by saving you a lot of time,
but also saving you a lot of money. I
lost a lot of money making a ton of
mistakes and trying to break out of
these loops myself. And so what this is
going to do is it's going to help you do
that for less money and less time. And
so I highly recommend checking out the
link below. It'll go into way more in
depth and show you kind of everything
that's in the platform more than I've
talked to here. And of course, you don't
have to get the program. We talked about
ways for you to break out of the
learning loop and the self-sabotage loop
already. And so feel free to keep going
about it on your own if you want and if
that works for you. If not though, I'll
see you inside.